the love and support that's most needed
in China right now the news popping up
on their phones is mostly to worrying so
are the scenes and some cities and the
viruses epicenter Wuhan checkpoints are
everywhere with the lockdown in place
streets have completely emptied out your
woman when we face a new type of virus
of which a lot is still unknown a lot of
people may feel anxious psychologists
have been deployed in hospitals to treat
patients and experts are there to
instruct people on how to protect
themselves
Beijing says it has the situation under
control
images released by the state media show
that supermarkets have sufficient
supplies and prices are stable but some
dismissed those images as propaganda
this student from Thailand in Wuhan has
had a different experience it's very
difficult to find stuff like if you want
to buy it right now because there's a
shortage everyone wants to stock up but
it's already too late you know it's very
tiring to go out wearing so many dresses
and washing it one layer of shirt one
jacket and one overall jacket so that
take three layers and I wear masks and I
wear cap and two girls trapped at home
some people have followed an online call
chanting Luhan do your best from their
windows
[Applause]
smart gestures to lift people's spirits
like this light show in Wuhan flashing
words of encouragement everyone here is
waiting and hoping that life in the city
can soon return to normal let's get the
very latest now with our correspondent
Matthias Berliner joining us from
Beijing good morning to you
Matthias can you bring us up today on
date on what authorities are doing to
get this epidemic in check yeah the
authorities have gone from zero
practically zero response to everything
they can throw in within one week now as
we have seen Wuhan and almost the entire
province is locked and everywhere people
are warned not to go out as you can see
here behind me this is a fever clinic
some people are queuing up there but
it's not a lot I think here in Beijing
the number of cases is not that high yet
but people feel very uncertain about
what that means the number of infected
cases the official number is now four
thousand five hundred that might not
sound like a lot for a country of 1.4
billion people but it is double of what
it was yesterday and we still do not
know whether this number is accurate at
all we have lots of reports that people
have not been reported by authorities
death have not been reported and people
have been quickly buried without
registering them as linked to this
epidemic all this is very hard to verify
but people are very anxious now and one
woman I just spoke to told me that she
thinks that citizens are probably better
prepared for this epidemic then the
government and they are now doing
everything to avoid contact with other
people to stay at home okay staying at
home is one form of advice the
government's giving the Beijing the
government's also come out and told
citizens to delay all travel abroad
what's behind that what is the directive
exactly
well it's the same same that is behind
the locking down of the epicenter of
this epidemic the government thinks the
less people travel the less the disease
can spread but what we know is that this
comes did all these measures they came
after the New Year's holiday the busiest
travel season in China had already
started and on Sunday the mayor of one
said just prior to the lockdown five
million people had left the city so what
is needed now and this is what experts
criticize is a lot of transparency is to
identify cases as soon as possible
because the people I have already
traveled they are already out and the
government is now trying to identify
people who have traveled to Wuhan before
trying to lock them down some people
have been placed under house arrest
after their travel we don't know how
systematic this is but it looks a lot
like a panic reaction okay Matias
Bolinger with the latest for us from
Beijing thanks very much for now well
with the coronavirus continuing to
spread scientists and pharmaceutical
companies are racing to find a way to
medically contain this virus lessons
learned from the SARS epidemic nearly
two decades ago may help them in
developing a vaccine it is a race
against time before the virus has a
chance to mutate China has begun testing
an HIV drug to fight the new corona
virus that is spreading rapidly the
medication known as alluvia
or Caleta prevents the virus from
reproducing in effect slowing down the
spread of the infection chinese health
authorities requested the drug according
to a spokeswoman for us from a suit
akil's company at v-- scientists around
the world are racing to develop a
vaccine against the disease Chinese
researchers were able to quickly
identify and share the genetic sequence
of the new corona virus allowing
scientific research teams to get to work
right away
they hope to build on the data and
research gathered during the 2003
outbreak of the severe acute respiratory
syndrome or SARS the disease is also
caused by a form of the corona virus the
research teams are pursuing several
different approaches with global health
agencies hoping at least one treatment
will be ready for human trials within a
few months the new virus is not as
deadly as mer sources but scientists
fear it could mutate into an even
deadlier and more contagious variant
okay so how possible is that for more
we're joined by Fabien Schmidt from our
science desk in mourning Fabien the
latest numbers from China are causing
lots of concern today almost a doubling
of the number of cases in one day is the
spread of this virus increasing in speed
and reach it certainly is increasing in
speed and reach because the virus is
highly contagious there were some
question about whether it really is
contagious already during the incubation
period which means before people show
symptoms whether that is true or not
it's clear that many people who are sick
are staying home which also probably
means that when we're talking about the
4,500 people have been infected this is
probably far too low figure because
those people are staying home or not
that severely sick but still have
serious symptoms but are healthy
otherwise we'll probably never be
registered um Fabien there's a lot of
focus right now on the development of a
vaccine to deal with this how promising
is that how long could that process take
the point is that basically there was
never in history a case in which a
vaccine had so much promise to be
developed in such a short time we're now
talking about three months American and
Chinese researchers hope that basically
they will be able since the gene
sequencing took place already to be able
to develop a vaccine within three months
and already go into human tests
then by summer it could be on the market
the question that really is there is
will the epidemic or if it turns to
become a pandemic which it might is this
going to last that long or is a vaccine
going to it's a market when it's
basically already too late now that
brings us to the second question we
already heard in the report about HIV
drugs that could be used to curb the
virus that's one hope that this is going
to make the process a little milder the
second one is an Ebola drug that some
researchers also consider as a potential
cure for the virus which means if you
have a infection already it makes the
process a little bit smoother and your
recovery faster okay so a number of
options out there
fabien thanks very much from that Fabien
Schmidt from ours science desk